moins de 10 degrés dehors et pas
beaucoup plus à l'intérieur des maisons
face à la flambée des prix de l'énergie
plus d'un britanniques sur trois et tout
simplement contraint de couper le
chauffage une situation si critique que
des médecins prescrivent désormais du
chauffage sur ordonnance à leur patients
les plus fragiles
il y a différentes techniques pour se
réchauffer c'est ça aussi la survie
d'être capable de se tenir chaud
n'importe quelle situation
[Musique]
c'est très important le chauffage
en Angleterre et en Australie et on se
rend pas compte voilà on se rend pas
compte des avantages qu'on a en France
de la qualité de vie qu'on a de tout ce
qui nous est payé tout ce qui nous est
facilité et donc voilà c'est facile de
se plaindre comme vous étiez là-bas vous
vous disiez ben la France c'est quand
même un pays extraordinaire quoi
[Musique]
sauf pardon j'ai pas entendu sauf la
mentalité française c'est à dire le fait
de se plaindre voilà mais on peut
répondre
vous vous depuis 3 minutes vous parlez
la propagande du gouvernement donc
oh là là franchement pas ça papa avec ce
que je viens de dire la propagande
justement vous vous contredisez
justement mais non justement
je suis un peu plus quoi j'en peux plus
te voir ça des Français toujours en
colère qui font la gueule non stop c'est
insupportable alors oui il y a des
malheureux en France il y a de la
pauvreté il y a de la misère mais je
crois que c'est partout dans le monde en
fait ce sont des prisonniers qui ont
participé à l'assaut du Capitole c'était
le 6 janvier 2021 alors ils ont
carrément leur propre groupe de musique
en prison qui s'appelle Jay six prison
corps c'est-à-dire la chorale des
prisonniers du 6 janvier on écoute en
extrait de cette chanson
[Musique]
moi j'aimerais bien aller vivre à
l'étranger pour une seule raison d'abord
parce que j'ai envie d'être avec des
gens chaleureux avec des gens souriants
avec des gens qui s'amusent avec des
gens qui vivent un peu dehors je ne peux
pas je ne peux pas parce que ici il y a
un système on va dire
social et médical qui fait que grâce à
ce système je suis encore vivant et que
je peux encore vivre plutôt décemment
Donald Trump c'est Donald Trump que l'on
entend parce que Donald Trump a
participé au projet dans cette chanson
on l'entend déclamer le sergent le
sergent le serment d'allégeance au
drapeau américain c'est un texte auquel
on sait qu'il est très attaché qu'il y
avait d'ailleurs rythmé son mandat
l'ancien président a spécifiquement
enregistré cette déclaration depuis sa
résidence de Marc à Lago donc clairement
il fait partie intégrante du projet
alors je vais faire Homer Simpson alors
c'est quelle phrase
[Rires]
et alors tous les ans notre petit
plaisir pendant le salon c'est de suivre
les concours agricoles les 40 vaches qui
sont ici c'est vraiment le top si vous
voulez faire la comparaison on est un
peu comme une élection Miss France pas
sûr de la comparaison 300 ans c'est
notre chiffre du jour si rien n'est fait
il faudra 300 ans pour parvenir à
l'égalité homme-femme un chiffre brandit
par l'ONU et par son secrétaire général
Antonio Gutierrez qui estime que dans
bien des pays comme en Afghanistan la
condition des femmes est piétinée que
pourrait-on vous emprunter mais que vous
ne voudriez plus qu'on vous rende après
l'avoir utilisé
[Applaudissements]
un mâle qui se comporte mal nufle
c'est pas le muffle mais un mal qui se
comporte mal le muscle c'est super le
président du groupe LR rappelle alors
plusieurs affaires concernant notamment
Eric Dupond-Moretti oui mise en examen
et pardon monsieur le garde celle du
garde des sceaux usés l'un et l'autre de
prise légale d'intérêt pendant
qu'Olivier marlex descend de la tribune
le ministre de la Justice fait alors des
bras d'honneur ils n'ont pas été filmés
mais vu par les députés oh là là dis
donc
on a les je vous laisse 30 secondes on
va pas réussir à vous départager
c'est Cyril Hanouna
face à Baba tout ça le succès
j'ai au félicité j'ai trouvé ça très
cadavre
darka ça veut dire drôle
le petit échange Éric Dupond-Moretti le
garde des sceaux
il y en a deux mais accompagné de parole
à chaque fois qui sont
de quoi vous parlez exactement vous avez
fait deux bras d'honneur c'est ce que
vous êtes en train de dire à l'Assemblée
alors oui je vous demande effectivement
de préciser vos propos parce que si
c'est le cas ça n'est absolument pas
admissible n'est pas adressé aux députés
Marleix c'est un bras d'honneur à la
présomption d'innocence vous venez quand
vous voulez ici il y aura pas de bras
d'honneur j'insulte plus les députés
j'ai arrêté j'ai mis un patch
début de la séance pour Gérard à 1h26 du
match
la séance surprise et voici Gérard à 3h
du matin
a-t-il mangé du fromage blanc a-t-il
Labello pour aller dévaler les pistes ou
a-t-il simplement produit ce qu'on
appelle dans le jargon du fromage de
bouche envoyez vos réponses sur papier
libre et bon appétit si vous êtes à
table
alors les amis vous avez le visuel
vous avez le son mais heureusement vous
avez pas les odeurs parce que là le pot
qui va d'ouvrir je vous garantis que ça
des boîtes
chaque année on se dit que les
emplacements des enclos par contre sont
pas hyper bien choisis par exemple voir
les vaches qui sont à 10 mètres de là où
elles seront l'an prochain
qu'ils ont une pile en face des petits
cochons trop mignons
un poster géant on referme ses
actualités avec notre feuilleton du
moment les débats au Sénat qui hier
proposaient une soirée spéciale il faut
que vous nous dites ce soir puisque on
commence à avoir
digier pardon bah oui c'est le soir donc
hier c'était by night de 21h30 jusqu'à
3h
c'est une danse qui a bouleversé la
France les pas du mari d'Agnès Lassalle
professeur tué à Saint-Jean-de-Luz
devant le cercueil de Safa depuis ce
weekend sur les réseaux sociaux on
relais massivement cette scène intense
tristesse et beauté réunies sur une
photo cœur et l'arme dans les messages
pour le célèbre chorégraphe Benjamin
Millepied c'est l'une des plus belles
dans ce qu'il est vu